le gouvernement français s'impliquent
pour la pratique du golf à deux ans de
la ryder cup organisée en france
au golf national et à un mois des jeux
olympiques de rio tri thierry braillard
secrétaire d'état aux sports était sur
place ce dimanche 3 juillet à l'open de
france de golf il est signé avec jean
loup charron président de la fédération
française de golf la convention
d'objectifs qui liera pour les années à
venir le ministère des sports et la
fédération
je vous propose de l'écouter c'est la
volonté de la fédération d'ouvrir ce
sport au maximum de jeunes filles et
jeunes garçons pour que plus tard ils
deviennent des vrais golfeur c'est un
symbole fort et puis dans quelques jours
les jeux olympiques avec pour la
première fois le golf comme sport
olympique
il y aura en 2018 la ryder cup qui sera
en france ici à 50 ans espère se nomme
un meilleur temps et puis 2024 la
créature de paris qui bien sûr intègre
le golf de saint quentin dans sa
candidature avec un joyau pareil c'est
un atout supplémentaire pour le dossier
et le ministère des sports et la
fédération une convention d'objectifs à
hauteur de 6 126 mille euros et 13
cadereyta sont mis à la disposition de
la fédération française de golf